yo welcome to this video this is wilson
palencia lets his real name actually so
international master i lost one game
against the sky of one game and tie i
have that wake memory that it was
something strange nope okay so i'm
playing there this anti does that i like
to play yep it's a possible way to go we
should be six bishop f7 but he has to go
g6 first hmm right doesn't look like the
most natural set up ever but probably no
way to refute it immediately so do i go
92 and then c4 hmm and that bishop here
on on g5 might get into some into some
issues so i'm giving it an additional
square down on f4 then h 2 i wonder if
c5 as a possibility it's a bit bitter
ambitious but ok it's going for for that
ok
why it's an interesting move I go Bishop
f4 and he takes on c3 that double porn
is kind of like doesn't it doesn't
really hurt that much i think i will get
in c4 and then i'm not sure if that
helped him yes that's true but after
should be five now that was a plan now
light b6 I saw that idea but I thought
no Bishop b5 now would be a would be
nice to to have so do a cheek it's not
okay that's not immediately necessary
but just make some sense for sure right
if five and also somehow feel attracted
to that move trying to do something on
the B file interesting okay Quinn before
that's an interesting idea now let's
activate he takes it that certainly not
something that our mind even though I
don't oops it takes it I did not expect
that hmm okay don't really don't really
understand why you would improve my
structure it's a bit bit of a mystery
okay preparing c4 here yes but who is
she going I don't don't quite get it to
e4 okay now let's see a bit mystified
what his ideas yes but at the end isn't
that isn't that good for me at the end i
don't i don't quite and don't quite get
it 95 and king d to this kind of thing
and then he has to go to e4 and I kekeke
and he can double up okay I can do this
okay if I go kinky 294 text x f2 hangs
that so that's an issue but let's do
this but that threatens knight c6 so he
has to react to that first I believe
interesting is that if he goes through a
six I can go a form that's a an
interesting IDM
the thing why I'm kind of skeptical
about legs place at this Bishop only six
is basically not on the board it's just
I mean it's just a top horn they're only
six and we'll never do anything in this
game maybe I'm wrong at this a five a
foul play is more important it's it's
it's possible but I'm still skeptical
and let's see 67 somewhat annoying Ruth
Andrew k6 that's a form a4a tix before I
takes b5 he does that ok if he goes to
e4 hmm if I take it he can't take with
the deep horn which was like give his
Bishop a little bit more scope yes it's
difficult to play for wind then but
that's definitely true as with the a
file he will have some some kind of play
now that's true but ok I can come knight
c6 and ask him why he's going with that
rook is he really giving me the pawn
their only seven I think I can really
take it there is well nothing great that
he can do a check here or if I cover the
first to be one or something and he will
cover the pawn takes it knight c6 back
to e5 ok
my goal is here to to trade them is
godrick a six many okay my goal is to
trade looks if i can trade rooks I've
got excellent chances here to to do
something
Bishop c4 95 on yeah probably 95k some
back or 35 that gets may be interesting
all right okay now I get the a file that
sets excellent that's a really weird
decision to one give me the iphone so
I'm going to put these on dark squares
first so that Bishop f1 that's never an
issue ok it tries to invade ok I have to
do this anyway so so time morning
well it is it is still an idea really
check TX takes rupes is 16g true king
entry and let this King is active so
there is Sir and now it's playing well
you know I never really get what people
do and sometimes they play I'm
shockingly bad and then all of a sudden
they start to play one great move after
the other and all that bloody eyeball is
moving and the threatening made black
vortex our idea what this is see winning
or something yeah he's winning what a
weird game what a weird game so I'm
probably probably mistaken in check and
doing this here that it's not really
working I didn't see that you get in
rugby 1 f1 h 5v h 5 is much stronger why
is g 5 mm look at six i had then this
will cover ok so that was the refutation
of the whole thing if should go h5 no I
didn't see that one I didn't see that
he's getting this counter play with with
rook be one f1 as I said it was very
strong play he saw that immediately
after he as I said giving me the a file
it's just shocking I mean this is just
this is completely bonkers yeah why
would you play would be 6 and give me
the a file yeah but the other stuff that
I played to inflate very well check so
yeah that was it was not the way to do
it I have to be to have to do
h5 yay around here it looks it looks
strange i said because of that dead
bishop but it's probably not as bad for
black as it looks even though this feels
kind of wrong he's after that capture
and it was difficult to avoid the
capture that bishop is coming back to
life and he's got the a file it only got
very critical frame when he completely
voluntarily gave they file to me after
that white wins yeah probably here g5
was stronger yeah d5 first bishop back
and then then I'm invading he okay that
was that was super clear actually I was
ass it was a very easy win yeah oh I
didn't play that technical part well
yeah I was surprised that he took on
before but looking at the game it seemed
to be a it seemed to be playable really
maybe a four was better here but okay I
didn't really think that was so good ok
here now a for was a good move but I had
this this position in mind from the game
f3 is stronger I am playing a bit in
precise IAM f3 is much better taking
away that ok i was i was tempted oops
I'm sorry i was tempted check bye bye
night against bishop because um in a
pure mind apiece end game I can play
this for a four-win forever and ever
because of night is much more flexible
in this structure than the bishop which
is as many pawns on the wrong color but
with this active rook and there's now
somewhat better bishop that's not a
problem for him so yeah at the end it
was a time scramble situation thanks for
watching